you don't know if you're more or
masculine than the three guys on the
left well Define masculine Oh my days
I'm not doing it yeah we are we're not
doing it all right there's some traits
that are feminine okay if I go like this
oh my god oh that's so not that's
feminine why it is why the construct of
what it is is feminine why
because it is
that's not good enough you can't just
say it is
not science I don't care I'm not doing
science yeah doing science what are you
doing I'm doing Street smarts Street
smarts yeah that's feminine okay
I'm sorry I'm intrigued do that again
[Music]
I'm looking at chess you have the
biggest chest as well oh thank you yes
wow you two would like go like one at
least definitely like one and two yeah
I'm not gonna lie this whole
conversation hit a little bit different
when there's a lot of lisps involved
what's he talking about see I'm just
saying and my leg does play a huge role
in my um confidence in myself and that's
a big reason why I'm so heavily tattooed
is to draw more attention
um away from my leg
oh
[__]
I'm so done
you know what I thought I thought this
guy just skipped leg day alive so I'm
like yo let me see them Twigs I'm like
oh there's a twig but honestly though
your physique yeah physique but it's
just I thought it was something
completely different hey whatever you're
doing is working because I did not
notice your leg I would put you number
two in terms of body I feel like I do
look like the most average out of
everybody here so I'm okay with that
average isn't a bad thing I go
it is a sickness
of the lowest order last carrier
although he went Harris isn't bad a lot
pause
no yeah I'm very plain I don't think I
have a style this is just gym shorts and
a t-shirt you should be number one okay
I think you know what though the thing
is it's not just about what you wear
it's about how you wear and how it fits
you I would say even though you wear
just shorts and a shirt like the shirt
fits you well you know and the thing
about fashion is like
what your body looks like is also going
to matter a lot for the clothes yeah
yeah you know so you could have the
Flies outfit technically per se but
somebody with a well-fitted outfit is
going to look nicer definitely you know
if we're just going to be like who's got
the nicest style quote unquote but it's
like how does your style look on you how
it falls on you uh you know the the the
choice of the sizes yeah according to
your body um yeah where does your style
come from Georgia at some point I got
really tired of like trying to force
myself to be accepted by other guys it's
just such like a frustrating Dilemma to
like force myself into that I just like
started just choosing what I thought was
cool men in skirts like prints and Kid
Cudi queer men trans men women a lot of
women inspire me like I feel like you
are inspired by lesbian women I'm
inspired by my girlfriend
what the [__] what the [__] did you say
the dude's wearing a plaid shirt and
some skinny jeans that is like one of
the most regular white dude looking
things I've ever seen AKA lesbian no
that that no that was less feel you got
inspired by by lesbians yeah I feel like
homie on the right is only in first
because nobody trying to get canceled
yeah because if I'm being honest with
you he going to the bottom half but
anyways
I would switch you two because you both
have acceptable like guy like he looks
good fashion but I like the color yeah
you can definitely puts more the earth
tones
I would put you number two and you
number three just because of the colors
I like the Rhymes not rhinestoning the
sparkling and you guys put effort into
like jewelry accessories okay
are you cool with number three yeah yeah
I'm so happy that the body type round
was done first it allowed me to feel a
little uncomfortable at first and then
it made me realize once I did put the
clothes on how much clothing makes me
feel more beautiful and attractive
if you thought like this is a very
masculine person who's like your prime
example of the first person that comes
to mind is my stepdad
um he really stepped up and took my mom
in when she was sick get that guy to the
right all the way to the left you
probably like Beyonce well to the left
to the left it's just cold
[Music]
if that's what we're doing
no you don't have to Define masculinity
wearing pink does not mean I'm not mess
with and being a girl boss does not make
you any less of a man hey you could girl
boss it sure you can get keep it and you
can Gaslight it as much as you want and
still be incredibly feminine sure yes
there's nothing wrong with Fighters
going from like this to it okay this is
also a fighting style it allows you to
catch the palms and the dicks
yeah yeah once that [__] hit though I
see your face crank
trust me you probably sometimes the
dicks come at you from all angles you
cried in front of me he has cried in
front of my mom I know we separate
femininity and masculinity but like I
think if your Peak femininity or Peak
masculinity you're in tune with both
sides of your emotions honestly growing
up masculinity was taught to me as
pretty much just an absence of emotion I
knew that that was wrong so I've just
been like masculinity femininity it's
not even real we're just taking traits
that all humans can have in applying a
word to it so I don't know why I said
I'd like to just throw myself at the end
I don't like the modern version of
masculinity so I would associate myself
with it they know they know they know
they know they know to the left of the
lift obviously you are very influenced
by your stepdad for sure and if that is
your definition of masculinity and
that's the healthiest definition I've
ever heard you deserve to be here I'm on
my own journey and like I still got to
get my anger under control too I don't
understand but you had an opportunity to
look at someone who maybe not mastered
it but understood both sides of the
spectrum therefore I think your
upbringing and your way of seeing things
makes you deserve the spot I like that
you said too you were like I'm still
working on it if you had told us that
like no you're the perfect one already
huge masculinity then you're gonna
deserve the top Squad no one will ever
be like a perfect man but that mindset
will make you a perfect man that means a
lot that's that's pretty cool you give
Dad energy yeah I am a dad so I
hope I'm trying to be better for my
daughter you know so so I appreciate
that means a lot let me get up here for
everyone yeah I had to make a switch I'd
switch you and you just Vibe honestly
but where do you feel like you belong
because you don't have to switch if you
don't want to I don't know I I actually
don't know I think masculinity like we
said is one of these topics where it is
changing every single day like something
new comes out and then it's like oh well
it's masculine to do this it's not
masculine to do this and it's like you
know it really depends on where we've
been throughout our lives what we've
experienced and what we've gone through
you don't want to say it
you don't want to say but come on now I
I don't know I don't know you think
you're less masculine you don't know if
you're more or less masculine than them
you you don't
like you don't know if you're less
like they ask you the question where do
you place yourself and you said I don't
know so basically you're telling me you
don't know if you're more or masculine
than the three guys on the left well
Define masculine Oh my days I'm not
doing it yeah we are we're not doing it
yeah yeah you want to make it you see
Hello Kitty we say Hello Kitty what's
wrong with Hello Kitty you're saying
it's not masculine Oh my days no it's
not and then we have pinky pinky over
there to the left you don't know if
you're at least so wait let me ask you
something if they just all swapped
clothes would they switch places because
of the clothes are you just judging
their masculinity based off what they're
wearing on them no I mean it sounds like
you are that's all you mentioned you
mentioned Hello Kitty and pinky pinky
but they also have that I don't have to
mention all that so the fact that
they're gay
yes gay makes you feminine no not
necessarily it depends what kind of game
there's some gay people that are very
masculine okay there's some gay people
that are very feminine damn them yup I
said that
[Music]
the aggressive nature of your toxic
masculinity is crazy high right now okay
yes let's bring it down a few notches
come on fix the feng shui no no that's
stupid you're doing too much that's
stupid let's carry on watching but that
whoa
who wrote trigger abuse nah Come on B
let's carry come on trigger no no no no
I'm not gonna [__] this I don't trigger
sugar what
what the [__]
what the [__] trigger the yelling just
brings back certain past memories
being a whole ass [__] again all right
let's get watching but I think this is a
question that transcends you know six
spots I think this is something that
we're gonna deal with for Generations
though based on that answer and you're
admitting that you are working through
your emotions I don't feel like I'm at
that level yet so I would put you here
based on that one I'd say it all kind of
boils down to like hormones if that
makes sense and like testosterone versus
estrogen naturally our testosterone
levels are going to drop as we get older
does that make us less of a man in your
eyes then because like okay I'm like
less of a man I don't think less
masculine either okay so then should
that be a valid argument in terms of
masculinity I guess when I see a man
like I was able to see like kind of
straight away like where you guys stood
if that makes sense like I saw you guys
as more feminine I think a man it's more
about like dominance if that makes sense
do you think I'm less dominant than you
it's like facial wise I don't know I
can't explain it basically I'm less
dominant than you I like how the two
guys on the right side oh my God
Michael's gonna get canceled
I don't think he's entirely wrong I
don't think he's entirely right is this
but [__] why is he saying yeah you're
more you could be you could that's the
thing I don't think it has nothing to do
with dominance you can be feminine and
dominant that's fine that's fine but
we're talking about masculinity all
right there's some traits that are
feminine okay if I go like Fast
um oh my god oh that's so not that's
feminine why it is why the construct of
what it is is feminine why
because it is
that's not good enough you can't just
say it is
not science I don't care I'm not doing
science yeah doing science what are you
doing I'm doing Street smarts Street
smarts yeah that's feminine okay that's
feminine
yeah
that's feminine absolutely you can't see
a really masculine man be like hey [__]
okay
I'm sorry I'm intrigued do that again I
didn't catch it the first time you did
it I'm sorry what was that
I'm sorry I didn't catch it it's for
science hey [__]
go ahead no go ahead I'm sorry I missed
it so what was it good for the science
for the same reason some people in the
comments think I'm gay or say oh [__]
this [__] zesty like if I'm like
if I do this
is it's a feminine trait it's not just
that you do that it just looks natural
on you yeah yeah and there's some
feminine things make it look effortless
yeah it's not like you've been a bad
[__] your whole life
[Music]
okay let's keep watching Girl boss
damn boss hey girl boss I guess my
definition of masculinity is more
traditional in a sense I feel like
everyone was maybe like a more newish
like you know not that there's anything
wrong with that and I don't think that's
necessarily
real if that makes sense like realistic
I think it's it's like ingrained in us
like I can't describe it even like when
I see someone you could kind of tell if
that makes sense okay so yeah you base
it on more physical and that's totally
fine yeah that's totally fine growing up
it was always like either black or white
you know where my parents are like
you're masculine you're super tough
you're super strong and you're there at
the head of the household you're always
that or you're like feminine so that's
something that I've always like kind of
seen that's why I was able to see both
sides of like where Michael was coming
from and feminine is not about weakness
and then I've seen some feminine people
very tough
very tough still feminine
so it's just a different energy
masculine feminine there's nothing wrong
or bad about that it's just really
different energy that's it
I think I'm kind of pretty
you're very nice smile that's right
you're a very very nice one I have a lot
of moles
um and I don't have a lot of moles on
the rest of my body it's just all I just
look like a chocolate chip cookie
um cookies are hot and then I got um my
scarf when I busted my lip
um playing tag on crushes like a couple
of months after my amputation I think
I'm lower on the end for sure even man
so people like scars it's a bit of word
place and what it is you know what I
mean so who it's intriguing stuff like
that of him I put you three you two
you won for now okay sounds good yeah
why is that I just think they're more
attractive to be honest
I don't know anything you guys both have
very nice skin and so that's why I think
you guys are beautiful well thank you
but yo Ryan Garcia on the left should be
higher for sure definitely higher than
[__] Iranian knows over here
you seem so uncomfortable with the idea
of being judge distracted I'm actually
okay with this spot just because like I
make like anxiety takes so like I tend
to pick up my face so that's why I have
a lot of acne there's no way Ryan Garcia
is is going way after Toucan Sam these
these ratings are crazy
these ratings are crazy all right I
think I'm a very symmetrical face though
and you have a very bright smile so I
think you could also be further up
I would put you here if anything
how do you guys feel where do you think
you belong I think I'm higher okay I
don't want to be narcissistic if there's
ever time to be narcissistic I can look
at you and I could see myself getting
lost in your eyes you have very pretty
eyes you have you don't have to do too
much like you're just attractive so I
would like to place you here to my right
sounds good
you also don't but there's like there's
something like no no no no no like
there's something no like I say that
because I've had an underbite my entire
life and I got made fun of a lot in
middle school and in high school even
now like on the internet that people
think I have features of someone who has
Down syndrome because of the almond
shaped eyes the underbite kind of just
like this weird looking so
a little too honest but I'm mad at it
because I prefer two one it's the not on
this Tinder that was one
that was crazy
shout out to him why is it crazy
huh why is it crazy
because it's true cause I see it
as soon as he said down Central like oh
[__] there goes my little special ed I'm
completely fine staying where I am
totally fine with that I'm just saying I
get what you mean there's just something
off wait let's talk about these
almond-shaped eyes because that's always
been a beauty
you guys could have just left them alone
and last in peace now y'all gotta start
lying at this [__] he accepted
it bro bro came in with a whole clown
noise all ready [__] he like he knows
he's just going through a bad breakout
at the moment like this is not necessary
if there's one thing I hate
when I've been in my really unattractive
periods is being lied to about how
attractive I am it's just it really is
irksome okay I feel like you okay now
you're just making fun of them you're
doing too much because I find you
attractive and moved on but you got to
be like let's discuss this oh my God
so my profile's dead nobody's wiping
like nobody want anything okay no no
you're good you got a good thing going
on just that are you interested
and also just to call out even if you
had Down syndrome I don't think that
would eliminate you from being the most
attractive spot
yo you know I'm so sick of these people
saying this goofy ass [__] but they
would never be caught dead dating any of
these people the most attractive
sorry it's pretty inappropriate for this
conversation did you get what I'm saying
yeah that was pretty aggressive yeah you
understand
I would put you up a second because we
got to hear your story too yeah you'd be
cool stories yeah thanks man nobody you
know [__] about no story types of beauty
bro
this [__] whack you guys have more I
feel like extroverted personalities so
you're more introverted yeah I'd say
yourself kind of do I'd say Nick should
be higher personally
I think you're a beautiful man so
hilarious okay if we're if we're basing
it on like personality and looks yeah if
I looked at personality and looks and
even if I wanted to boil it down to like
right swiping or left swiping I'd write
swipe will not leave
what
hey yo bruh
so
you're uncomfortable about love hey man
they just some straight needs to be
doing the most thought about it if I was
you know start swiping all you [__]
and handsome
anyways was it ah there you go yes this
man is straight huh yes decide to
volunteer information no one has asked
for he said if I was gay I would go
inside you
who wants this information but that's
not what these manners have asked for
true I witnessed it with my own eyes
they did not choose to make him more
deviant he has come here he has said
look make a dance maybe I was going to
call him a day all right well my anus is
going to be ruptured and I'm going to
enjoy it this is what he has done
it is a sickness of the medium order all
right let's just do this real fast so
you guys can know where I rank amputee
jean shirt
Ryan Garcia
pink black dude and then Rudolph
I think it's a pretty easy ranking
what about y'all wherever you guys right
I think this whole ranking is cat busted
I think it's really kept
do you think this would have been
different if there wasn't three gay
dudes on the thing well if there was
different people it would have been
different because
it would have been different people yeah
I just felt like the gay dudes came with
that like somebody might get canceled
energy now that they were pushing that
no but I think because of the fact that
they were gay and they were different a
lot of these dudes seem reluctant to say
a lot of the [__] that they was thinking
sure or maybe I'm being unfair and maybe
these dudes just put a bit like this in
any scenario we'll never know honestly
it seems like
it didn't even make sense well I know I
did make sense
him being last doesn't make any sense no
because he wasn't last in any category
no it's a weird stuff so he was never
last but then ends up last I'll just
think it's because he didn't have the
most Progressive attitude they ranked
the other day the First on overall
Beauty why because he had a cool
backstory and you know I mean like I
don't know
ah unless what you guys think in the
comments